♪♪
M'BAKU
The Black Panther lives!
RYAN COOGLER
The way we went about making the first
movie was with as much respect for
the cultures that we were pulling from.
We wanted to do the same thing for the
cultures that we were reflecting in this.
LETITIA WRIGHT
I'm excited about the new characters
that we introduced to the world.
TENOCH HUERTA
For me, it's a dream.
I never imagined playing this character.
RUTH CARTER
Wakanda itself is such a concept.
We really wanted to come
back to it and groom it.
ANGELA BASSETT
Ruth just took it up a notch.
She will exhaust every
possibility to build this world.
I know so much more of who
I am when I put the costumes on.
RAMONDA
Have I not given everything?
ANGELA BASSETT
You want to take an audience on a journey.
You got to grab them by the heart.
LETITIA WRIGHT
You see the themes of family.
Protection. Love. There's so
much that's happening.
RYAN COOGLER
Hopefully, you see something in it
and it speaks to you personally.
LETITIA WRIGHT
You got to keep inspiring people
and I'm praying that will be
the result of this movie.
SHURI
Yibambe!
ALL
SHURI
Yibambe!
ALL